what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again as promised to
explain exactly how strong yet another
hashira is i said i do this one if we
got 4 500 likes on the mitsuri video and
we got over 11 000 right now so here we
are discussing the final hashira out of
our main generation that i have yet to
cover next i'm thinking of possibly
doing how strong is genya but if you got
another character that i haven't covered
and you're burning up to see then leave
a comment below and it may be the next
video i do either way i'll start on the
next video asap if we can reach 5500
likes on this one i repeat 5
500. so spam that like button like
there's no tomorrow because doing so is
tangible energy and not doing so is
demon king of pop energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demon slayer videos and updates
that's just the way it works and finally
while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos on all the demon moons
all the hashira and much more link to
that is in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into it
and start discussing one of the most
interesting characters in all of demon
slayer spoilers and all shinobu had a
happy childhood until her parents were
killed by demons shinobu and her sister
kanae were saved by gyome the rock
pillar and decided to become demon
slayers themselves however as if losing
her parents wasn't enough kanae
shinobu's older sister also died at a
demon's hands at upper moon two's hands
no less this was when shinobu was 14 and
when we meet her during the natagumo
mountain arc she is already 18 years old
now that i've explained her backstory
you can imagine how much shinobu must
hate demons however she hides her true
feelings often and even says when the
core leader sends them to natagumo
mountain that and i quote it would be so
nice if humans and demons could get
along don't you agree tomioka end quote
she comes off as even more tolerant
towards demons than giu for a second who
responds as long as demons eat people
it's impossible end quote in truth
though giu is the one who insists on
trying to save nezuko later a demon
while shinobu at first at least would
love nothing more than to kill her but
more on that later shinobu finally shows
up at the battle scene in front of
zenitsu after his fight asking if he's
okay she saves him and it's revealed
that she's a poison medicine expert so
she's definitely the perfect person to
find the poison dying zenitsu she then
shows up to take care of one of rui's
underlings the demon can't hit shinobu
who calmly avoids her attacks the demon
can't help but think that shinobu's aura
is so strong it even stopped her breath
the aura is also cold and makes her want
to curl up like death is at her side the
coldness is one of our first clues that
shinobu is not what she appears to be
with her often smiling face she's not
the nice girl that just wants everyone
to get along that's just a front
although shinobu says that she wants to
help the demon lady at first it soon
revealed that her main priority is to
actually punish her so she can atone for
the people she killed it's immediately
apparent that she's not like tunjura who
feels pity for the demons he kills for
shinobu it's not enough to kill the
demon she wants to know exactly how many
people the demons killed so she can make
the demons suffer more than necessary
before they die our smiling pretty
shinobu says she'll gouge out the
demon's eyes cut open her stomach and
pull out her guts then she'll let her
feel that pain and only then will the
demon's sins be forgiven so as we can
tell shinobu is a very vengeful person
when the female demon refuses to go
along with that plan for obvious reasons
who would want to be tortured painfully
shinobu easily dodges her attacks and
stabs her in multiple places faster than
the eye can see and faster than the
demon can react the demon realizes that
shinobu has a small body and soft arm so
she can't actually cut off her head and
she's actually right that shinobu can't
cut off a demon's head but she's wrong
in assuming that she can win because of
this fact shinobu doesn't even have to
attack again before her poison takes
effect and brings down the demon as she
explains some warriors like her use
poison she's the only one of the hashira
who can't cut off a demon's head but she
can make poisons that can kill demons
the next interesting thing we see is
shinobu and giu actually going at it
because shinobu wants to kill nezuko and
giu is protecting her shinobu is not
afraid to play dirty either possibly
trying to throw giu off his game by
saying that everyone hates him after he
blocks her attack even when tanjiro
explains that it's his sister shinobu
just says too bad and decides to use a
gentle poison that will still kill her
but without as much suffering notably
giu is not confident enough in his
skills to be able to protect nezuko on
his own he tells tundra to run as he
tries to hold off shinobu now yes he
can't use his full strength probably
because he doesn't want to kill shinobu
but still if he was significantly
stronger than her at this point he could
have easily stopped shinobu from hurting
nezuko even without tanjuno's help i'd
still say giu is stronger at this point
but just saying he had respect for
shinobu's speed and strength enough to
take precautions to ensure nazco's
survival he does end up capturing
shinobu to his credit but while shinobu
is distracting him with words and saying
everyone hates him again she unleashes a
blade from her heel and is about to stab
guillo in the head before a crow stops
her by saying that they are to take
tundra and nezuko into custody not to
kill them so giu is stronger but shinobu
is willing to use every trick in the
book to win she's machiavellian and
clearly not held back by empathy not
only is she horrible towards demons she
was even willing to stab a fellow
hashira in the head just because he was
getting in her way all of this gives her
an edge and makes her even more
dangerous in battle than anyone would
expect someone who isn't even strong
enough to cut off a demon's head to be
fast forward to the infinity castle arc
and shinobu runs into upper moon 2 doma
and this battle is the single best
measure of her true power and
capabilities since she has to give
everything she's got in this fight and i
mean literally it is a very significant
battle for shinobu because when her
older sister was dying from lethal
wounds she explained to shinobu that the
demon that killed her looked like blood
had been dumped over his head kinda
actually wanted shinobu to live a normal
life but shinobu refused saying she must
avenge her sister and that there's no
way she can live a normal life now end
quote as soon as she sees doma she
recognizes that this must be the demon
that killed her sister the demon she's
been wanting to get revenge on all this
time in a sense her reason for living
was to avenge her sister by killing this
monster in particular as shinobu swoops
in and seemingly saves one of doma's
female victims from being devoured by
him doma comments and i quote wow you're
fast are you a hashida end quote he's
being super patronizing here and it's
revealed that shinobu wasn't actually
able to save the victim but still coming
from such an insanely strong opponent
it's worth noting that shinobu speed is
praised and this won't be the last time
either shinobu who can usually mask her
dark side with a smile can't help but
lose her cool and show her true feelings
against doma the demon who killed her
sister as she jogs his memory by showing
that she's wearing her sister's howdy
coat doma finally remembers and starts
saying that kane her sister was kind and
cute he couldn't absorb her because the
sun came up but he really wanted to and
as he's talking shinobu uses some of
that insane speed to stab doma in the
eye once again doma praises her saying
it was an amazing thrust and he couldn't
stop it with his hand as shinobu moves
back to avoid one of doma's ice attacks
he again comments that she's fast very
fast nevertheless doma thinks she's
pathetic because thrust techniques can't
kill demons the head really has to be
severed he says but then shinoba reveals
that she's using poison and to herself
wonders if this poison will work on an
upper moon notably this poison is
stronger than the one used on ruiz
mountain that we recently discussed doma
does succeed in breaking down this
poison and says he's looking forward to
the next compound and to her credit
shinobu isn't worried saying she's
anticipated everything so far as the
fight continues shinobu unleashes the
move compound i hexagon after which doma
remarks once again that she's fast and
more importantly that she may be the
fastest hashera he's met so far huge
praise however even as he says this he
was fast enough to cut shinobu during
her attack without her even noticing
doma does go on to say that given her
speed if she could cut off his head and
not just poke him she might have been
able to actually beat him shinobu in
response hates the fact that she's so
little and lacks necessary muscles and
starts to doubt herself she's crying and
kanna's spirit must come to her aid she
tells her to stand up while shinobu
thinks that she's lost so much blood she
can't even stand her left lung is
punctured and so she can't even breathe
but kana is not having any excuses
saying none of that matters once you
decide to defeat a demon defeat it
whatever the cost and she reminds
shinobu that she did make that promise
with her after all thanks to kanna's
spirit shinobu succeeds in pulling
herself up despite sweating heavily once
more doma is very impressed that she can
stand after all her injuries he's
surprised she's not dead full credit
goes to shinobu's mental strength here
even doma feels pity for her saying the
pain of the blood gurgling and her lungs
must be beyond imagining shinobu decides
to aim for doma's neck believing if she
can hit him there with everything she's
got she can still win she uses the move
dance of the centipede hundred leg the
zigzag and starts quickly and powerfully
weaving in all directions she's so
strong that everywhere she lands she
breaks the bridge beneath her feet and
she's so fast that dolma says he can't
predict her attack and to her credit she
out speeds upper moon 2 here and comes
in low and actually stabs him in the
neck pinning him to the ceiling the way
shinobu and her sister viewed things was
they didn't have to be the ones to stop
muson if they could even defeat one
demon they could save dozens of people
and better yet if they could defeat an
upper moon they could save hundreds so
for shinobu she already saved many
people but defeating this upper moon
would save at least hundreds more and
even avenge her sister it is a very
important victory for her character arc
she landed the attack and doma looks
like he's affected she thinks to herself
it isn't about whether we can or cannot
there are things we have to do and this
was one of the things she had to do she
admits to herself that as tundra guessed
she is angry her parents her older
sister and more were killed by demons if
not for demons they'd be living happy
lives right now she drops the mask
completely here and admits that she's
furious and it doesn't help matters that
the poison didn't work and doma heals as
if that epic final attack didn't even
hurt him doma goes on to absorb shinobu
into himself since he loves absorbing
women and says he's impressed that such
a weak girl could do so much he tells
her that she didn't have her older
sister's talent but she's still done
well when asked for her last words
shinobu tells doma to go to hell defiant
and angry to the end and then she's
absorbed and kanel shows up in time to
see it happening but can't stop it and
so although she did well and was heavily
praised for her speed and effort it
looked like that was the end for shinobu
poison wasn't enough doma had healed
from everything without issues but
here's why this is my favorite fight and
why shinobu is such a great fighter this
was all part of the plan by absorbing
her doma absorbed the wisteria flower
poison she had been consuming regularly
for over a year with tamayo's help she
was already planning for this battle and
even planning for her death long ago
wanting doma to consume the 37 kilograms
of wisteria poison about 70 times a
lethal amount with her the toxin takes a
while to kick in but when it does it is
what allows kanao and innosuke to
finally slice off doma's rotting neck
there's no doubt about it shinobu didn't
do it alone but without her inosuke and
kanel would not have been able to defeat
upper moon 2 doma and it's just a
perfect ending because doma even
remarked that she was weak and not as
talented as her sister and yet she was
the one who found a way to defeat him
albeit in an unconventional way and with
help from others there's no doubt about
it shinobu was amazing here and truly
helped make this fight my favorite fight
in demon slayer so to wrap things up
shinobu was physically the weakest
hashira she couldn't cut off a demon's
head and even her blade was modified so
that was more like a stinger for
injecting poison into demons than a
full-sized blade as a result she created
her own breathing style insect breathing
in order to make use of her strengths
she was already fast and her modified
blade and original breath style no doubt
helped make her even faster as doma says
she might have been the fastest hashera
doma ever saw which is saying a lot and
he said that before she succeeded in
outspeeding him and pinning him to the
roof so arguably she is the fastest
hashira he ever saw she was also very
intelligent and her mind was arguably
her most valuable weapon her knowledge
of toxins allowed her to not only help
beat doma but to help produce the toxin
that would ultimately help take down
muzon too and her long-planned strategy
against dolma was the single best
strategy i can think of in the entire
series it allowed her inosuke and kano
to defeat doma even though one upper
moon is supposed to be the equivalent of
three hashira and this isn't just one of
the upper moons we're talking about but
the second strongest one in straight up
strength i've placed shinobu below the
other hashira as you may have seen if
you watch my all hashtag rank from
weakest the strongest video gui had an
easy enough time overpowering her albeit
they probably weren't going full out but
he was able to first catch and then
restrain her furthermore most of the
other hashtags go on to unlock upgrades
like the demonstrator marks and red
blades while shinobu doesn't so my
ranking still pretty much stands but i
hope i've shown how much more there is
to a character than just strength
despite arguably being the weakest
hashira shinobu was one of the most
useful using her knowledge and sacrifice
to help defeat doma and even muzon she's
one of my favorite characters and we
should respect her more not less because
she was able to accomplish everything
she did while being one of the weaker
fighters among the hashira and that is
it for this one i really hope that i
added to your respect for shinobu
because she truly is one of my favorites
and so is her character arc simply
amazing if you did enjoy this video you
know what to do channel the slayer
within and smash that like button
remember i'll start on the next video
asap as soon as we reach 5500 likes i
repeat 5
500. so spam that like button with no
mercy because doing so is tundra energy
and not doing so is demon king of pop
energy just remember to let me know if
you want to see genya or another
character covered next in the comments
if you haven't make this the video
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates that's
just the way it works and finally while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the demon moons all the
hashira and much more link to that is in
the description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord wigo
himself alpha sigma and other one-tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans ingrata al-jatal
cory mcgowan the spike kaido might be a
gyarados dylan isadore spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist cody
hebert and jeremy cummings and our pro
hero to your patrons the one and only
gilgamesh the red-haired raven steelers
angel crews very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy games
and jessica rabbit thank you all so much
if you also enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com anime outdoor and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course thank memes so check
out patreon.com anime upload link in the
description if you're interested you can
also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content either way
whichever way you support us you'll get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you